Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass euch die Videos gefallen haben.
Wenn ihr gerne mehr Videos von mir machen wollt,
dann abonniert meinen Kanal,
lasst einen Daumen hoch,
und wenn ihr mir noch weitere Videos von euch sehen wollt,
dann abonniert meinen Kanal.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Also dann...
Eh?
Geht das nicht?
Twitch-Layout hat es wieder eingeklappt.
Wunderbar. So, auf geht's!
Bei All-22-Juess-Bedke.
Keine Chance, aber man muss wieder arbeiten gehen.
DAKUXTW,
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Jaja, alles Top.
White-pepo-happy?
Äh, White, nicht white.
white nicht white white breit breit pepo happy
ja lul wehberg ja was willst du
ich sag ich ich werd wieder vollzeit youtuber easy
geht der bot eigentlich im discord wieder
leute ich war echt geschockt weil das was ich heute gelesen habe
es ist schon zwei tage her aber ich habe es heute erst gelesen
ich war echt geschockt und zwar stellt euch vor google
sekunde ich muss mal die news suchen
google nimmt alle sugar daddy dating apps aus dem store
was ist da los hier jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich gerade 37 geworden
das heißt in drei jahren ja wenn diese apps genau das richtige für
mich gewesen aber nein jetzt jetzt ist vorbei ja was soll das denn
meine güte
was was was ist hier
wofür jetzt mal blöde frage jetzt mal ernsthaft was was ist
eigentlich genau der sinn dieser apps jetzt habe ich jetzt dazu ein bisschen
was genau ist eigentlich der sinn also so wie ich das sehe ist im endeffekt sind
diese apps doch dafür da dass man als alter sack junge mädels quasi von sich
überzeugt in dem man ihnen geld gibt oder also im prinzip so ein bisschen wie
only fans nur in echt
ja dann okay dann sehe ich das dann sehe ich das richtig alles klar gibt so
was auch umgedreht ich glaube da gibt es keinen markt für oder ich proklamier die
eigene dating app easy da gibt es bestimmt noch marktlücken quasi quasi
real life only fans genau genau ja so so ungefähr kann man sich das
wahrscheinlich vorstellen leute ich habe übrigens vorhin vpn verwendet
richtig heckermann style seit jahren mal wieder in vpn verwendet
wollten einen film gucken festgestellt gibt es noch auf amazon komm und ich auf
amazon de beziehungsweise gibt es überall überall aber halt nicht in
deutschland weil er kein deutschland in den kinos läuft
vpn ich habe dings geguckt ja
das da weiß ich ob das jemand schon geguckt hat von euch ich weiß ja nicht
irgendwie als das merkwürdig und dann habe ich nachgeguckt habe ich nachgeguckt
das ist von den gleichen leute das ist der was das nachguckt ist der grund
warum ich mir angeguckt habe das von den gleichen leuten die hardcore henry
gemacht haben was auch eines der merkwürdigsten filme war die ich je
gesehen habe ja und der ist also ich würde nicht sagen dass es guter film ist
zumindest deswegen habe ich vorhin mal vpn angeschmissen weil man den nur in
usa gucken konnte und ich nicht eingesehen habe da irgendwie ins kino
zu gehen oder sowas wozu dass der film kam vor einem jahr raus
installer schwache also ich würde es nicht unbedingt empfehlen zu gucken sehr
random irgendwie was kennst du den typ der eine dating app erfunden hat und
seine freundin hat da einen anderen typ gefunden
nö aber wenigstens hat er was dran verdient ist auch schon mal das ist mehr
als die meisten typen also mehr als den meisten typen wo das passiert aber
da habe ich so geld bekommen davon so jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken lautstärke
ist ok ja gut ganz ehrlich ich hätte lieber eine erfolgreiche dating dating
ab erfunden meine freundin sucht sich einen anderen anstatt die freundin zu
behalten wenn sie freundin anderen sucht dann ist es wahrscheinlich schon nicht
so sonderlich rosig gelaufen oder habe ich lieber eine dating ab mit der ich
massig kohle verdiene mark ldm dankeschön 14 monat subscription
die kommentare leute bei mir auf youtube habe ich wieder leicht ausgelöst heute
was mauf da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen und zwar ich habe doch dieses
video über new world gemacht so und da sind ich ich koll jetzt nicht also ich
ich deute ich deute jetzt kein spezielles raus weil ich immer weil ich
ungerne namentlich quasi abonnenten flame aber da sind teilweise kommentare
dabei wo ich mir denke was ist mit den leuten los warum gibt es eigentlich wie
nennt ich hab mal eine frage an euch chat eine ernst gemeinte frage ja sims auf
da auch fakt das darf man gar nicht mehr sagen also wir sprechen es jetzt
rückwärts aus ihr wisst was ich meine also auf twitch ist das sagen wir mal
ein durchaus bekanntes phänomen was für mich ja unter anderem einschließt dass
man es sich ja dass man sich vieles schön redet ja so und wie nennt man denn
wenn jemand simt für spiele also so richtig ich mein im prinzip fanboy nur
nur noch nur noch eine runde härter weil das fällt mir bei games immer auf wenn
die wenn die leute es nicht ertragen dass man was negative sagt und sich
alles aber auch alles aus den fingern saugen um sich das irgendwie schön zu
reden gims schillen console wars im prinzip die
gleichen leute die jetzt blizzard verteidigen bei world of warcraft immer
noch so was zum beispiel ja so im prinzip die ultra hardcore fanboys meine
ich also die die bei world of warcraft aktuell noch sagen ja aber das ist doch
egal hauptsache das spiel ist gut was im prinzip auch nicht stimmt das die
lucia fernbeus ja genau die dann sagen ja es ist auch gut dass es den in game
shop gibt weil dann weil dann kann sich keine ahnung irgendwie jeder doch alles
leisten und so und so wo betty gibt es immer noch ich war immer noch zu faul
war zumindest also also lange rede kürzer sinn was mich echt erstaunt hat
dass unter dem video viel ich bin jetzt wie gesagt kein namentlich leute flem
es haben unter dem video viele leute geschrieben max die die ich habe in dem
video gesagt ich frage mich wie das endgame von dem spiel aussieht ob das
irgendwie eine substanz hat weil ich für weil es für mich so aussah als hat das
spiel quasi alles aber nichts davon in der tiefe so und da habe ich gesagt ok
es ist richtig dass die auf vielen hochzeiten tanzen aber ich frage mich
halt wie sie das wie sie das machen wollen gerade man kennt von mmos die
leute das game kommt raus die leute kreinden und nach drei monten drei
drei wochen sind alle max level so und jetzt und jetzt ist halt die sache die
da haben die leute gesagt max die frage nach endgame die stellt sich doch jetzt
gar nicht das ist doch nur ne beta da kommt auch
sicherlich ganz viel content raus so und da denke ich mir so natürlich stellt
sich die frage nach dem endgame ich habe heute morgen in den stream rein
geguckt ja ja das video ist gut für den algoritmer so keine frage das haben
die random es haben bei mir 10.000 leute geguckt und über die suche 44.000
gefunden so jetzt passt mal auf die beta ist heute fertig und wisst ihr was die
leute heute morgen gemacht haben in new world ich habe heute morgen mal auf in
der app auf in den stream und wisst ihr was die leute heute morgen gemacht haben
in new world world first oder ich weiß nicht ob sie world first ist aber ich
vermute mal world first die haben in der beta jetzt haltet euch fest in der
beta nach 14 tagen max level fast max gear und den letzten boss den es in dem
spiel gab gekillt in der beta nach 14 tagen
das ist doch im prinzip genau das was ich gesagt hat die haben nix endgame
technisch selbst wenn es doch wunder was reinkommt bis das spiel rauskommt die
haben nix endgame technisch und dann hast du noch dann hatte ich auch noch
leute die kommentare die gesagt hat max dass darauf darauf sollten die darauf
sollten die hersteller eh nicht achten der weg ist das ziel und sonst was das
sehe ich komplett anders mmos müssen gerade gerade was ich hab grad moment
bisschen mein saft geleppert lull ich sollte nicht labern und noch mit einer
tasse in der hand des rumschwenken das wollte ich jetzt an kreis mmos müssen
endgame content bieten den 70 prozent der leute erst mal nicht sehen
du musst noch zu irgendwas aufblicken können oder zu irgendwas hin arbeiten
können es ist doch total bescheuert zu sagen
hey wichtig ist dass das game quasi die ultra der ultra casual nach ein halbes
jahr unterhält ja und was machen die leute die das ein bisschen intensiver
spielen werden das ist für alle schlecht wenn man den game so balance vor allem
hey guckt euch mal an news seiten news seiten so news ein über was berichtet
eine news seite nehmen wir mal wie heißt wie heißt diese deutsche mmo news
seite die hat die keine sau mehr liest aber früher recht groß war
baft baft oder oder wie heißt das andere mein mmo oder irgendwie so was
die game sei gelb sei lesen auch viel also denkt euch mal in die x beliebige news
seite aus die beispielsweise über mmos berichtet über was über was berichten
die berichten die world first boss clear oder berichten die der 5000 ultra
casual hat jetzt den dungeon zum 300 mal geklärt und hat immer noch gesagt dabei
über was berichten die bitteschön eher natürlich brauchen die ordentliches
endgame wohin die 0850 leute vielleicht eine weile darauf zu arbeiten aber wo
sag mal die hardcore leute maßstäbe setzen das muss so sein
wie sollen so wie sollen so die können doch schlecht erst endgame erst stellen
anzufangen damit wenn die hälfte der casuals in die nähe kommt das wird doch
nichts und was machen die leute gerade mmos leben mit davon dass du keine
ahnung 5 5 prozent 10 prozent der spielerbasis irgendwie absolute 0815
kreisel grinder sucht die sind egal wo ich jetzt mal darüber auslassen und da
habe ich meine bedenken ich glaube nicht dass es standhalten wird
an der dankeschön für den zapp muss ich jetzt mal los werden ich muss mal kurz
in meinen dashboard gucken weil ich glaube die hälfte übersehen habe
an der dankeschön für den zapp da wir haben ansonsten noch satans linke nippel
hat subscribt warum der linke hat ich dachte satan hat 666
engel dankeschön für den zapp mark ldm danke für den zapp und jetzt ist mein
ding mein dashboard komplett umgejammt
das gem train ist am start leute lasst lasst euch lasst euch schön scam von
twitch abfalle als nächstes kommt der enkeltrick mal gucken wir mal das macht
immer twitch so kurz kurz gerät alles gut ja was lassen wir überlegen was was
ist denn sonst noch halt passiert was mich irgendwie ausgelöst hat oder auch
nicht was ich ach ja es gibt das youtube premium light habt ihr das gesehen
und hier es gibt jetzt youtube premium light was immer noch doppelt so teuer ist
wie drei monate youtube in indien zu kaufen
ok was auch immer den sinn davon ist ja da sind da sind da ist nur werbefreie
videos drinnen alle anderen features fehlen alle anderen features verwendet
aber eh niemand hat jemand von euch meine frage habt ihr youtube originals
geguckt so was gab es da scare pewdiepie und solche dinge habt ihr jemals in
youtube original geguckt ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe nie nie nie ein
youtube original geguckt und mich interessieren youtube originals auch
absolut null das einzige wofür ich youtube premium habe ist keine werbung
und eventuell eventuell benutze ich irgendwann mal das download feature
ja background play klar background play werbung background play ok wenn das kein
background play hat ist schon mal sinnlos wir suchen einfach mal wir gucken
uns bei die offizielle beschreibung aber zu was premium premium hat warum findet
youtube wenn man nach premium light sucht denn nicht youtube als erstes
hier schauen wir mal premium light steht hier noch gar nicht drinnen check wait
ja ist da ist da background play drin vielleicht vielleicht ist pc games
besser background steht nichts zu da man ohne back ohne ohne background play ist
das ganze reichlich sinnlos so viel kostet der pc von dokter disrespect das
ist mir doch vollkommen egal das ist ja nichts was irgendwie realistisch wäre
dokter disrespect lebt davon dass der über überzogene dinger treibt und
natürlich ist der pc auch überzogen youtube premium light der channel weiß
es wieder guck mal hier ist offen ist not available jebaited youtube kein
background play ok das wichtigste feature ist nicht vorhanden ok ich mein man
muss sich mal überlegen wir sind wir sind weit gekommen ja wir sind im jahr
wir sind im jahr 2021 es gibt eins mal es gibt eine smartphone app die videos
musik und alles abspielt aber man kann sie nicht benutzen weil man die sache
nicht im hintergrund abspielen kann wusste die dass das früher ging
wusste ihr dass die alten also ganz alten youtube apps die konnten ohne
probleme im background abspielen android und android ist gar kein problem das
ging das haben die vor ein paar jahren ausgebaut damit können wir geld
verdienen ich mein man muss sich das mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen eine app
kann einem die funktionen seine smartphones nehmen im hintergrund
abzuspielen das ist richtig das ist eigentlich gestört wenn man sich mal
überlegt twitch ist ja kein problem twitch kannst du background abspielen
twitch ist sogar so schlimm dass es teilweise wenn sie begrenzt vor der
line wieder angeht weiß ich ob das einer von euch schon mal gehabt hat
einfach runterladen kostenlos mit musik play hat das ist unter ios alles gar
nicht so einfach ios ist halt ich habe gar kein apple bild fällt mir gerade ein
was include ja kein back background play das ist halt fehl aber mal ganz
einfach leute kauft euch einfach youtube prämien in indien youtube prämium in
indien das kostet euch 340 oder 349 indische
rupien natürlich eine währung wo jeder weiß wie man das nach euro umrechnet
das sind umgerechnet glaube ich 3 euro 3 3 euro 14 oder so keine ahnung aber
dreiviertel indische rupien euro 395 4 euro also man bezahlt 4 euro für drei
monate youtube prämien über indien dass die steuerhinterziehung warum du bezahlst
doch mit einem deutschen paypal und alles das was warum sollte das steuern
also alles ich verstehe wenn youtube sagt das ist gern aber warum um alles in
der welt sei das steuerhinterziehung sein du zahlst aber nicht für drei
monaten die rupien sondern für einen für drei monate bezahlste 349 rupien
du kannst über vpn machen das geht ich mache es immer per browser weiterleitung
über die indische vm ich hole mir immer bei digital ocean
hetzner hat leider kein indisches rechnzentrum sonst würde ich das über
meinen partner hetzner holen bei der ausrufe zeichnen hetzner in den chat
da könnt ihr euch ein 20 euro startgut haben code einlösen für eure zukünftigen
server experimente ich hole mir immer bei digital ocean vm in bangalore indien
leite da drüber den browser weiter und logge mich ein und und hole mir drei
monat youtube prämium
also wenn da wenn das schleich ist dann habe ich das wort schleich nicht
verstanden also viel offensichtlich kann man
werbung ja wohl kaum machen hier oder
darfst du in der anderen haus darf alles machen was ich will das einzige was was
ich nicht machen werde ist beispielsweise in den titel jetzt digital
ocean oder so schreiben und dann den hetzner sponsor stream zu machen ich kann
alles erwähnen was ich will so lange es jetzt nicht gerade irgendwie den sponsor
stream mit sponsor segment ist oder was ich glaube es geht los ja jetzt
wir werden es noch treiben und drei drei tage ohne bett ihr aushalten
sponsor bei nord vpm ich lasse mich nicht sponsoren die haben wir heute wieder die
haben wir heute wieder geschrieben die haben wir wieder mein ich lese es euch
vor warte mal warte mal ich meint man ich habe auch wieder was gekriegt ich
lese euch das mal vor zeigt das mal wie man das macht mit der browser
weiterleitung soll ich das zeigen da muss ich jetzt in digital
ocean vm anlegen ok warte mal wo sind die wo sind die denn hier
also doch aus dem habe ich es erst letztendlich du brauchst den ssh
weiterleitung ssh-y so vpn opportunity vpn campaign opportunity max fbs habe ich
heute gekriegt ok mal gucken wer es ist achtung postchamp postchamp leute für die
meisten leute von euch ist es glaube ich deutlich einfacher sich ein kostenloses
vpn zu holen und das zu machen in indien also wir haben einen vpn campaign
opportunity max fbs hello nein nein nicht hello hey there hope you had a great
weekend mein name ist naomi ja ganz bestimmt mit sicherheit mit sich mit
sicherheit heißt du naomi ganz ganz klar
and i'm contacting you from was von wehm from great works
ah influencer agency alles klar ok ok die kann doch naomi heißt ich dachte
dass es ist in china china chinesen agent der da schreibt ne ok wenn ihr aus
london kommt da kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen dass sie naomi heißt ok
i'm contacting you today as we are on running a campaign with a vpn service
and they would love to work with you ist klar weil mich auch so viele da kennen
garantiert und sie die haben einfach geguckt sortiert youtube ok alles klar
alles mal anschreiben and see if you'd be interested in doing a 60 to 90
seconds integration in one of your videos ja wie heißen die jetzt it would
be great to know your fee ja das kann er das schreibe ich zurück ich schreibe
zurück ich sag einfach 2800 euro man muss irgendwie was sagen was viel viel zu
hoch ist erst mal wenn die da drauf eingehen dann mache ich das auch dann
mache ich auch dann mache ich auch vpn werbung kein kein ding wie die verraten
gar nicht welcher vpn anbieter das ist was ist denn hier los
ach das ist ja
sagt ja
leute sander börn ist mittlerweile so unübersichtlich
ich finde manche knöpfe überhaupt noch mal dafür die vier euro sind normales
youtube premium leid ist unsinnig leid würde ich nicht kaufen
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das nur die ur ist aber alles klar
max nicht in 2,8 kann sondern 4k ansatz ja ja ist klar das werden ich bezahlt ich
weiß noch es hat sich letztens einer gemeldet und wollte irgendeine videoschnitt
software anpreisen mit mit also pass mal auf die wollten das letzte mal die haben
ich angeschrieben ob ich den video videoschnitt software
promoten will da habe ich halt zurückgeschrieben naja gut ich kann
das ich kann das gerne promoten wäre werbung würde ich sofort machen
habe ich gesagt ja gut ich kann das promoten aber ich will jetzt nicht den
leuten vor lügen das habe ich ein bisschen ich habe so ein bisschen
geschrieben dass ich das irgendwie verwenden würde ich habe keine lust mich
in die software einzuarbeiten aber wenn ihr gewisse punkte habt die ich sagen
soll und vorgefertigtes video kann ich da gerne 30 sekunden was zu erzählen und
aber ich kann halt nicht meine persönliche empfehlung aussprechen oder
sowas da habe ich ihnen halt geschrieben ja gut für 800 euro können können
drüber reden ich habe absichtlich schon so ein bisschen
schmerzgrenzen mäßig genommen das ist eigentlich schon sehr ordentlich für
grad für meinen channel aber ich habe mir gedacht wenn ich darauf einsteigen dann
warum nicht und dann haben sie gesagt nee das ist das ist ihnen zu viel und sie
haben gesagt ja wenn ich für wenn ich für was haben sie geschrieben 200 euro
machen würde dann dann wären sie dabei oder habe ich mir nur noch gedacht
alles klar ich weiß ich preis den leuten in in also unskippable reingerenderte
werbung 60 sekunden garantiert für 200 euro ganz ja ich bin ich mein man muss
es vielleicht nicht immer bis auf den letzten cent rauspressen alles aber man
muss es auch nicht von apple und ein machen
gut das ist kein problem wenn man das wenn man das deklariert also ich bin wie
gesagt keine rechtsberatung oder sonst wie na gut das würde ich nicht sagen
nein es ist ja ein unterschied ob du sagst es ist gesponsort und du dann
erzählst so nach dem motto das ist die beste video schnitt software die ich je
verwendet habe und keine ahnung dieses video ist auch mit dieser video software
entstanden oder so du kannst du kannst viel scheiße erzählen solange es
deklariert guckt euch das mal an guckt euch doch mal werbung im fernseher an
meint ihr wirklich was weiß ich mir fällt jetzt kein gutes beispiel ein
thomas gottschalk früher fand haribo so geil wobei doch ich glaube der fand die
wirklich geil wie gibt es mich ja in schumacher hat
werbung gemacht für sonst wie irgendwelche fußballspieler
der dings hier es ist manuel neuer was ist das doch mal für eine werbung
ich weiß es machen so viele leute werbung im fernseh und sagen wie geil
das produkt ist obwohl die das in wirklichkeit selbst nicht verwenden war
das hätten shoulders pepsi nein nein kohler zwar kohler ne
coke zero ja genau genau du kannst du kannst da die alle kaufen dazu zu sagen
dass das geilste geilste produkt aller zeiten das er auch nicht verboten es
muss halt als werbung zu erkennen sein das würde ich tatsächlich sogar noch
am ehesten von diesen ganzen anfallen die derzeit bekommen machen ja sogar ganz
sogar ganz ohne big stonks naja gut da soll es sich so umgehen also ich kann das
jetzt nicht zeigen wie ich das mit dem mit dem indischen browser macht also ich
kann ich kann ich habe jetzt mein log in nicht da und dann liege ich mit
irgendwas oder oder oder hast du nicht gesehen kann keine ahnung also ich gehe
zu digital außen wobei warte mal mal gucken ich ich gucke mal ob ich meinen
account finde wenn ich meinen account finde dann zeige ich euch zu schnell wie
ich das mache aber wenn ich mein account passport und gedöns nicht da hab dann
zeige ich euch das nicht digital außen
habe ich clipboard aus ok ok leute ich ich zeige ich zeige es euch kurz
und mal kurz ausmachen dass die kram ordentlich copy pasten kann sein in
was kostet das screenshot tool schon da die poggers ok verify code wo habe ich
mein handy oh nee jetzt muss ich noch muss ich allen ernstes mich noch im
zweite account einloggen und in der email bestätigungscode reinhauen was ich
nicht für den chat alles mache white people happy
jetzt mal leute in den chat jetzt ist der scheiß auch noch im spam ordner jetzt
muss ich mich im browser einloggen ich muss mich im browser einloggen in den
spam ordner gehen und den kod von digital außen raussuchen also ich ich
bin schon da ich nehme ich nehme schon viel auf mich ja
jetzt kick mich auch noch gmx raus bin aber gmx jetzt kick mich auch noch gmx
raus weil sie der meinung sind sie wollen wir premium verkaufen ok digital
außen kod verify kod alles klar ok ich hab's geschafft
default project ok poggers ok ich mache ich mir da an also ich zeige euch jetzt
wie ich das mache beim also ich erstelle eine vm digital außen warum digital
außen weil die weil die in indisches rechten zentrum an create droplets das
ist easy das ist wirklich easy also ihr sucht euch irgendwas aus nimmt es
irgendwas egal das wird das wird minütlich abgerechnet ihr bezahlt am ende
2 2 2 cent 50 oder so also keine ahnung wir nehmen ubuntu server keine ahnung 8
giga 8 gigabyte 4 4 cpu 48 euro im monat vollkommen ok wie gesagt wir
löschen das ding eh nach 20 minuten wieder so volume frankfurt ne bengalore
bengalore indisches rechten zentrum ssh key root password key blub blub blub
alles klar create droplet wunderbar aber der gelegen haben wir die vm anmachen
es kann übrigens sein dass es fucking langsam ist und gar nicht richtig
funktioniert jetzt weil abends ist die verbindung nach indien immer wahnsinnig
schnell
der desktop das pock richtiger richtiger poggers desktop sagt mir was ich finde
es sagt was sagt was ich finde es leute was was soll ich finden magic
ich sag euch sofort wo sie ist banshee zimmer ist nicht drauf auf dem desktop
ist auch nicht drauf liegt ist auch nicht drauf
ea pdf das ist hier gefunden beim easy ich weiß nicht was sie ea pdf ist ich
will das jetzt nicht aufmachen was ist die ea pdf warum liegt das da kann ich
da reingucken sekunde
moment warum liegt das da was ist das die akso ja das ist ja langweilig das
muss ich das muss ich umbenennen das muss ich umbenennen
das ist das bullshit bingo für für in der e3
jetzt muss ich den titel schreiben
bullshit bingo dass ich das nächste mal weiß das sieht das sieht so aus als
hätte ich in der nda oder sonst was hierhin kopiert von battlefield gedöns
ich darf sie nicht aufmachen weil sonst weil sonst name liegt und und und alles
und und und liegt liegt liegt das liegt liegt dann so also ich zeige euch das
jetzt ihr machten server dann kopiert euch die ip ssh minus y gut et geht auf
die kiste drauf dann ab update warten bis die indische vm die sache auf die
reihe kriegt ab install firefox zack man sieht schon wie lahm die ssh verbindung
ist das wird richtig das wird richtig eklig ich werde es wird wahrscheinlich
nicht richtig benutzbar sein machst du das noch als youtube tutorial ich weiß
nicht ob youtube das so mag wenn ich ein tutorial mache wie man youtube billiger
kriegt so das hier auf dem m board
das geht besser kannst du mal ja ja ja ich habe mich schon ein paar rausgesucht
so firefox installiert jetzt kommt reg 17 ihr loggt euch noch mal ein und dann
sagt ihr einfach firefox starten bäm und wenn jetzt die verbindung morgens ein
bisschen schneller ist dann geht es gleich in firefox auf der in indien
läuft leider leider ist das problem dass die verbindung nach indien extrem
langsam ist gerade abends guck mal ping das ding mal
ach du scheiße allein schon ping noch vor 150 millisekunden
das körper jetzt das das das dauert jetzt das dauert jetzt zwei minuten bis
der browser aufgeht warum kein proxy man kann das mit zig verschiedenen dinge
guckt so jetzt habt ihr ein browser in indien das könnt ihr über vpn machen
das könnt ihr über den proxy machen das ist egal das können wir machen wie ihr
lustig seid
wie bekommst du prämium für ein paar euro wie gesagt über indien kaufen
guck mal ihr seht wie lahm das ist da funktioniert nix die verbindung ist
wirklich wahnsinn wo ist der unterschied zwischen vpn und proxy
jetzt ist technisch was komplett anderes die das resultat ist das gleiche für mich
ist es einfacher weil ich habe innerhalb von zwei minuten vm erstellt innerhalb
von zwei weiteren minuten firefox aufgemacht und das zeug erneuert bis ich
bis ich bis ich in vpn aufgebaut habe länger guckt euch mal alter ist die
verbindung lahme also ich kann euch aus eigener erfahrung sagen es ist morgens
eine ganze ecke schneller es ist unbenutzbar gerade guckt euch das mal
an was ist meine ip können wir jetzt darüber ausführen
dann seht ihr ich bin in indien ich bin bengalore alter ist das langsam
guckt euch das mal an aber jetzt habt ihr gesehen wie es geht also ihr wisst jetzt
wie es funktioniert so mache ich das kann ich nicht empfehlen wenn man also
sich extra für einen account machen sonst was ist bescheuert ich würde
einfach ich würde einfach sagen nehmt ein proxy in den vpn easy fertig ja aber
ihr wolltet sehen so mache ich das
du kannst doch bei den proxy als fertiges image kannst du auch machen kannst du
auch machen kannst alles mögliche machen kann jeder machen wie er lustig ist ich
mache das so welt über ssh kann ich grüß aufrufen ja kannst du das ist nicht
sonderlich schnell aber es geht so guck bengalore bin ich ist es eine gute idee
an public peiholz zu setzen nee eher nicht
was droplets genau was das ist eine ganz normale linux vm ein droplet bei digital
ocean so und jetzt macht ihr hier über indien macht ihr euer youtube krempel so
und dann loggt ihr euch aus geht hier rüber und sagt beim destroy und weg damit
fertig easy und dann könnt ihr euch youtube für 3 euro 95 holen
ja ja also ich würde daheim kein public dns betreuen gibt ein paar sachen die
würde ich daheim nicht betreiben public dns gehört dazu und public mail
public smtb relay oder irgendwie sowas mehr relay würde ich auch nicht daheim
öffentlich betreiben aber wie gesagt einfach einfacher ist es für die
meisten leute wahrscheinlich in vpn aufzumachen oder in proxy zu verwenden
oder sonst was ich mache es halt so weil ich habe ich wie gesagt spieler da
schon eingelog ich mache einfach ein browser tab auf digital ocean dings
neues droplet angelegt zack zack zack also ich habe das in fünf minuten
erneuert und davon sind keine ahnung vier minuten das loggen und das bezahlen
public du kannst public nen pie hole betreiben aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht
den den großen sinnen dahinter
ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wie gut abgesichert pie hole in der
standardinstallation ist keine ahnung ich würde sie nicht machen bezahlen
methoden nicht eingeschränkt ist kein problem kanns paypal bezahlen du musst
nur für indien in deinem google account ein zweites profil in den zweit das
wie heißt es payment profile anlegen das funktioniert wie gesagt marschieren
marschieren monat alle drei monate
excellent keine ahnung der droplets ist der name von stink normal linux vms bei
digital ocean was sind deine meinungen zu den preisen von windows 365 ich habe
keine ahnung ich kenne die windows 35 hast du mal ein link windows 356 pricing
gucken wir mal alle mikro moment das ist das microsoft das brauchen wir nicht
microsoft reveals first office 300 mic windows 365 pricing ich checke die
microsoft benahmung nicht die hatten office 365 und haben das umbenannt in
microsoft 365 wo ist denn der sinn dass es jetzt windows 365 gibt warum gibt es
nicht microsoft 365 und winners 365 bestandteil davon was ist das ok pricing
die frage der fragen ist für mich wie es dort mit gpu beschleunigung aussieht
also wenn das einfach nur eine publische vm ist ohne irgendwie grafik acceleration
oder sonst was also wenn das im prinzip mehr oder weniger eine vm mit rdp ist
dann ist das für arsch
also dann wüsste ich nicht wozu man das wo der sinn davon sein sollte ist das
ordentlicher quasi wie nennt man das wie heißt das das gleiche was zytrex
macht virtual vdi heißt das vdi genau virtual desktop infrastruktur ist das
was gescheites mit hardware acceleration und dass man eben auch zugreif auf die
grafika zum beispiel für video decoder und sowas dass es ordentlich läuft dann
ist es gar nicht schlecht also dafür sind an 31 dollar im monat durchaus in
ordnung wobei 31 dollar im monat für eine dual core kiste
4g ram ist spiel sehr knapp
ist ein bisschen sehr knapp
gut dann wird es in deutschland genau das gleiche kosten eher noch mehr in
euro weil der kram ja immer teurer ist in euro als in dollar warum auch immer
oder ich lasse mich gern eines besseren besseren belehren aber meistens werden
die dollarpreise recht unvorteilhaft umgerechnet umgerechnet so
ich machs
ach guck mal da kann man kann sich das sogar da schon angucken ok also zeigt
mal her oh nee guck mal die die rechnen das
sogar relativ günstig um also was ist günstig vorteilhaft um verwenden sie
einfach was bis zu 300 nutzer was sollten das bedeuten wieso wie soll ich
in da 300 nutzer ok dann ist es dann doch per rdp oder auf der ding 300 nutzer
kein problem ma ma ma
das ist groß
so ok bevor also ordentlich ordentlich dimensioniert ist eigentlich das das
ist so ein ding warum gibt es keine warum gibt es keine 4 core 8g reicht
braucht nicht unbedingt 16 g für das was ich da meine das hier wäre
eigentlich so das was sinnvoll dimensioniert wäre aber 60 euro im
monat also weiß ja nicht das scheint mir doch ein
bisschen teuer zu sein ich mein ihr müsst euch mal überlegen für
diesen für diesen key mit dafür kann ich mir 20
ja 20 wenn aus zehn keys kaufen
was mich interessieren würde ist wie greife ich da drauf zu per dp per dp mit
irgendeine erweiterung geht es über ein browser wie funktioniert das zwei
monate lang kostenlos testen testen sie was ok das werden wir das werden wir dann
testen das schreibe ich jetzt gleich mal auf stream also wir testen wir testen
zwei zwei sachen in nächster zeit wir testen einmal chrome os das gibt es
nämlich als custom distribution zum selbst installieren da bin ich mal
gespannt und windows 365
da bin ich mal gespannt ob man das ordentlich benutzen kann ich kaufe ich
kaufe dann das fette und gut ist was ist denn windows hybrid
was was ist denn windows hybrid dass ich quasi lokal die session
fortsetzen kann oder wie
jetzt muss ich mich einloggen ja ja aber nicht wobei bin ich vielleicht
noch eingeloggt bin ich vielleicht noch eingeloggt vom letzten mal ich habe
jemand fake account erstellt den account test
ok das ist gerade procken wie es aussieht da machst du nix
wo man sein das nächste mann bei microsoft läuft gar nicht so gut was
das angeht ist wie es scheint
übrigens was ich heute auch gelesen hat was mich wieder wahnsinnig irritiert hat
dass so was überhaupt ein ding ist es gab wohl eine dating app für eine dating
app für impfge-gegner un-unjected was was ist der sinn davon dass man sich noch
noch schneller die sache einfängt oder was
ich weiß gar nicht dass apple korona regeln hat aber mal ernsthaft warum muss
man sowas verboten also warum verbietet man das wenn die leute dumm sein wollen
soll es doch dumm sein apple ist nicht dafür da der retter der menschheit zu
sein das sind sie noch in anderen gebieten auch nicht dass die leute dummes
zeug machen hat das problem schneller erledigt
da gibt es dann sicherlich nicht nur korona als ansteckende kranken ja bist
du geimpft ja ich bin geimpft aber ich habe auch nicht beide impfung ich werde
am klob 16 glaube am 16 kriege ich die zweite impfung ich habe biontech
gekriegt ich habe nix gemerkt außer dass mir ein bisschen der arme weh
getan hat jetzt sagen die leute biontech ist die zweite viel brutaler mal abwarten
mal gucken ich lasse das mal auf mich zukommen ich hoffe nur ich hoffe nur
dass sie nicht auf die dumme idee kommen eine impfpflicht in irgendeiner art und
weise einzuführen so nach dem motto lasst dich also bevor ich mich geimpft
habe so nach dem motto lasst dich impfen oder muss strafe bezahlen weil wenn sie
das machen sage ich den termin ab ich lasse mich freiwillig impfen weil ich
das für sinnvoll halte ich habe schon oft gesagt aber ich habe das gefühl die
leute scheinen aktuell total auf verbote und anordnungen zu stehen
anstatt einfach zu sagen hey die leute müssen selbst entscheiden was sie machen
und sollte es wirklich unter androhung von strafe dazu kommen dass ich mich
impfen lassen sondern mache ich das nicht ich bin ich sage ich sage das
instant ab ich hasse das perform und beziehungsweise wenn wir sachen auf
aufgezwungen werden ohne dass sie selbst entscheiden kann aber so weit so weit
wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht kommen hoffe ich mal und wenn es nach wenn es
dann passiert nachdem ich mich habe impfen lassen ja so wort dann ist durch
das ist ein risiko was wir tragen müssen du kannst keinem vorschreiben sich
impfen zu lassen das geht auf das geht auf gar keinen fall das müssen die
leute selbst entscheiden und wenn das ein problem ist dass die leute das nicht
machen dann müssen wir die leute überzeugen das zu machen oder wir müssen
mit den konsequenzen leben du kannst nicht du kannst nicht den
leuten quasi angeordnete körperverletzungen auf mit straf androhung
machen da sind wir eins vor china das geht nicht ich lasse mich impfen weil ich
das für sinnvoll finde weil ich auch hauptsächlich für mich mache aber du
kannst so was nicht nicht unter quasi unter strafe anordnen
es gibt was es gibt impfmücken sind das china drohen oder was 55 g drohen oder
was was darf man sich dann oder vorstellen
wie hast du eigentlich die zwangt ja das weiß ich auch nicht habe ich den habe
ich aber den habe ich aber bei der way so aktion finde ich gut ja das ist das ist
das ist super oder auch was manche länder machen so nach dem motto du hast
eine chance bargeld zu gewinnen wenn ich jetzt meinetwegen das sind vollkommen
legitime anreize wo ich sage ja ist gut kann man machen alles in ordnung aber du
darfst nicht sagen unter androhung von strafe du musst
habt ihr zu wie nachwuchs bekommen ich weiß es nicht ich war noch nicht auf der
arbeit diesen monat was die regierung hat mücken ausgesagt und wer ist noch die
idee schon wieder gekommen alter auf welche auf welche idee
das zum teufel ist das schon wieder das ist doch das ist doch jebait das ist
doch jebait was spricht gegen eine impfung nix aber die leute müssen
freiwillig machen das ist das das ist doch das was ich sagen wird sagt auch
nicht dass irgendwas gegen die impfung spricht ich sag dass natürlich ich sag
doch selbst ist es sinnvoll die impfen ich lasse mich auch impfen aber es muss
freiwillig sein das freiwillig ist ja mein punkt nicht ob impfung sinnvoll ist
oder nicht natürlich ist das simpel sinnvoll also das ist doch jebait das ist
das muss doch jebait sein das sind irgendwelche leute die drollen
mittlerweile die die drollen mittlerweile mit mit irgendwelchen
bescheuerten post oder und ein ich sehe die deutschen trends ich will die
deutschen trends nicht sehen ich muss die recht ich muss die rechte
hälfte von meinem display ausblenden warum trendet heute war ja hat jemand
olympia verfolgt heute war doch das gewicht heben wo loren ich hab vergessen
wie sie heißt der die die neuseeländische transgender frau mit
teilnehmen was die frau hat verkackt ok was ist da weiß jemand was rauskommt
die frau ist ausgeschieden weil ich richtig gehoben ok ja war vielleicht der
trotz der druck zu groß hat er die ganze welt drauf geguckt
ich hätte zu gern gesehen was passiert wenn die gewinnt dann dann wäre die
welt wieder mal für einen tag auf wird da komplett eskaliert
das hätte ich gerne gesehen ja natürlich kenne ich die southpark folge das war
natürlich typisch southpark wieder
also auf twitter hätte gewonnen wird twitter komplett komplett vorbei
twitter eskaliert jeden tag ja dabei was ich da auch nicht verstehe ist die
leute können das einfach nicht trennen die flamen dann die persönlich was
totaler schwachsinn ist die persönlich zu flamen ist das bescheuerte was du
machen kannst die hat sich an die regeln gehalten die darf teilnehmen gar keine
frage das ist das ist für mich überhaupt keine
diskussion also die persönlich zu halten dafür ist beknackt ja so lange man sich
an die regel hätten teilnehmen vollkommen vollkommen ok
aber über den sachverhalt wie sinnvoll das ist da kann man ja darüber
diskutieren aber noch nicht die leute persönlich angreifen das kann ich
immer nicht nicht nachvollziehen ok also was machen denn die impfmücken zeigt
mal her leute passt auf im sommer hat man
mücken gezüchtet die impfstoff
es ist egal ob der das oder ob sie das weiß oder nicht
ich sehe das übrigens auch so dass das nicht fair ist aber sie hält sich an die
regeln und sie wurde zugelassen sie wurde
nominiert dass es du kannst du kannst vielleicht diejenigen dafür
anscheißen dass die regeln so sind wie sie sind aber nicht derjenige die
regeln dann einhält und im prinzip nur das macht was erlaubt ist ich finde auch
nicht fair aber dass die persönlich dafür anzugreifen ich genauso
bescheuert so also was was was machen die impfmücken zeigt mal her so weit ich
weiß haben groß angelegte tests funktioniert soweit ich weiß woher
weiß er das wird mich mal interessieren auf ehrenbruder basis leute er weiß
dass er weiß dass er hat er hat da den durchblick soweit ich weiß haben groß
angelegte ich frag mich immer wie kommen die leute auf so was was oben steht auf
was mit demo im bild das ist das ist das ist auch die chatgruppe oder die leute
schreiben das immer so überzeugend leute trust me trust me das ist so das ist so
ok soweit ich weiß haben groß eingelegte tests funktioniert diese
mücken art stammt aus skandinavien aha warum die sind besonders resistent oder
wie das ist der troll message das kann doch nicht ernst gemeint sein es gibt so
viele leute die trollen mittlerweile auf twitter rum mit solchen sachen weil die
einfach gerne leute auslösen die triggern einfach gerne leute das
ok da sage ich gleich was zu ich will das war kurz die die message lesen also
diese mücken hat stammt aus skandinavien aha dieses auch noch bei temperatur nur
fünf grad aktiv achtet auf ungeschützte stellen ok das heißt wenn wir der
nick demnächst leute im ganzkörper kondom sehen dann wissen wir dass den
leute die sich vor den mücken schützen das muss die bait sein ich kann ich
glaube nicht ich ich kann mir nicht ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
ich klicke nicht auf die trends ich muss mich zurückhalten vor vor vor
deutschen trends auf twitter im gegensatz zu noch was zu normalen mücken
verursacht der stich einer impf impfmöcke
das ist so eine typische message die leute in meinem alter und älter auf
facebook teilen und dann dabei schreiben ich hab's euch gleich gesagt
so und im gegensatz zu normalen mücken verursacht das sticht einer impfmöcke
keinen juckreiz frage ich mich wie das gehen soll aber ok ist nicht der juckreiz
von mücken dass das quasi die ver die verunreinigung die die mit unter die
haut kommen durch was leute weiß jemand galli leo wissen jetzt gefragt durch
was entsteht der juckreiz eines mücken stichs ich also ich würde so aus
spontan sagen das ist eben ein schmodder was die mücke die quasi mit
unter die haut schiebt ja spucke spucke der mücken ok der chat weiß bescheid so
viele leute unabhängig davon sagen das gleiche der gerinnungshemmer ja was
das wird wahrscheinlich im speichel sein okay okay das heißt man merkt das
stechen weil die weil die mücke das nicht macht ok was die impfung mittels
impfmücken werden auf dem uns a achso ok ok mal ganz im ernst wenn ich
impfmücken aussetzen würde dann wäre der beste da wäre die beste
möglichkeit doch tatsächlich in die anti impf corona demonstration oder die
gegen demonstranten die ja bekanntlich bezahlung erhalten das finde ich auch
immer geil wenn die leute so was schreiben so nach dem motto also es ist
ja allgemein bekannt so nachdem man weiß ist man weiß es doch man weiß es doch
einfach ja bekommen ein serum dass die mücken davon abhältlich zu stechen die
antifa und politiker sollen konventionell von einem arzt mein hochwert alles klar
das muss troll sein das muss eine troll post sein ich kann mir also die leute
sind teilweise schon etwas merkwürdig in solchen gruppen gehe ich auch von aus
aber das das geht auch über jegliches also da reicht ja normale kreativität
nicht dazu aus da musst du ja schon drauf anlegen dir was auszudenken
ich weiß nicht das also das ist das sieht mir ein bisschen nach toll post
aus aber nicht dass ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass manche leute
so was glauben weil denkt an den an den exen mensch body als es ja meine
persönliche lieblingsverschwörungstheorie der exen der exen mensch
bodyguard von obama ich gebe zu das ist vielleicht schon ein
bisschen älter und ein bisschen abgedreht aber es gibt ja leute die
glauben das wirklich und leute die wirklich glauben dass obama einen
exen mensch bodyguard hat die glauben so was vielleicht auch das ist toll ich
glaube auch leute ich glaube auch dass es ein troll ist glaube ich auch so ich
habe doch gesagt vorhin hier sage ich gleich noch was zu wo ist es denn das
hier also das das problem beim impfen ist dass es sehr viele leute gibt die sich
nur impfen lassen dazu faul zur impfstelle zu gehen selber holen ist beim
organ spenden wenn eine bratwurst zwar 2 euro 50 ja sehe ich auch so sehe ich
auch so mit dem organ spender ausweis ich übrigens sehe ich übrigens ähnlich
wenn man die leute dazu bringt das zu machen ist es eine sinnvolle sache du
kannst aber dort auch bin ich auch dagegen dass man das obd out macht ich
werde erste der obd out macht ich würde ob in machen aber ich bin ich würde
sofort obd out machen wenn einer entscheidet was wenn mir einer die
entscheidung abnimmt das kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden ich mache das
wenn ich das für sinnvoll halte aber ich sehe es nicht ein dass quasi über
meinen kopf hinweg über mich soll ich sagen verfügt wird das kann ich nicht
ab
ja aber ist das das richtige feifert muft die sollen den leuten bratwurst
geben und gut ist wenn das anreiz ist das zu machen
wenn einer ein exen mensch ist dann ist es zuckerberg von dem habe ich lang
nichts mehr gehört was treibt er denn so hat man hat man hat man vom vom zuck mal
wieder was gehört in letzter zeit war recht still ich habe ich habe nur das
letzte was ich mitbekommen habe ist die eu wollte ihn ja vorladen und er hat
gesagt ich komme einfach nicht da war doch irgendwas ist aber auch schon
wieder ein jahr her oder haben wir gesagt ja gut dann halt nicht
schon spät na da haben wir noch zwei schöne zeit
doch wird es weil viele leute machen sich keine gedanken drüber und keine
gedanken machen beziehungsweise es kann nicht es kann nie so sein dass quasi
keine zustimmung automatisch eine zustimmung ist dann kriegen wir bei ganz
anderen sachen noch problemen deswegen muss so was immer opt in
sein wie gesagt ich halte es für sinnvoll zu machen sowohl beim impfen als
auch noch gar nicht mehr nach ausweislich zu holen und sei es nur dass
drin steht man hat keinen bock drauf dass man das dass die verhältnisse klar
sind aber es muss alles opt in sein da wird mich auch keiner wahrscheinlich von
abringen so war das war sonst etwas spät das halte ich nach wie vor für ein
troll dass das halte ich für das halte ich für ein troll kennt ihr mal einen
dienst bei dem man seine domain emails gut verwalten kann die meisten anbieter
haben doch so eine catch all die das dann zu einem anderen email anbieter
weiterleitet da braucht man doch gar nichts extra für
was haben was habe ich da eben gelesen sander bolt 5 ist nicht sander bolt 4
noch überhaupt nicht noch überhaupt nicht irgendwie verbreitet
sander bolt 4 hat auch kaum schon was oder das gibt auch kaum was mit seiner
bolt 4 sei daran ein
Wisst ihr was ich bei diesem ganzen Thunderbolt Thema wieder mal lustig finde?
Intel hat ja eigentlich gesagt, sie wollen, also ok das stimmt, das hat Intel so nicht
gesagt, aber das ist meine Interpretation dessen, was Intel eigentlich vorhatte.
Die haben gesagt, damals zu USB 4, sie wollen kein Thunderbolt mehr parallel neben USB raus
bringen.
Die haben das quasi damals übergeben an das USB Forum.
So, jetzt hat sich das USB Forum aber so unglaublich unfähig angestellt, dass Intel wieder gesagt
hat, ok, uns bleibt ja gar nichts anderes übrig, als das selbst zu machen wieder.
Das ist das einzige, wie ich mir das erklären kann.
Die haben ja damals zu USB 4 gesagt, ok, wir geben euch Thunderbolt ab, macht mal ordentliches
USB 4 und USB 4 ist der verschissenste, das haben die so, ich kann das bis heute nicht
nachvollziehen, wie man es so unklar und so wir uns so unsinnig machen kann wie bei USB
4.
USB Forum sind die größten Monarch-S Leute, ja, also ich glaube das USB Forum und das
C++ Gremium, das sind bestimmt zum größten Teil die gleichen Leute drinne, anders kann
ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Die machen vormittags neuen C++ Standard, wo keines auch durchblickt und mittags schreiben
sie neue Specs für USB.
Serious Max, du willst einfach nur, dass ich mich da drüber jetzt auch auslasse, du weißt
die Frage nicht ernst, du bist dafür viel zu oft da, als dass du das fragst.
Ok, was gibt es denn Neues, von 40 auf 80 Gigabit verdoppelt, ja gut, mit dem was die
vorhaben ist es ja auch sinnvoll immer mehr darüber zu packen, weil nicht nur SSDs, sondern
gerade auch, dass jetzt Grafikkarten und PCI Express drüber gehen, da ist mehr Bandbreite
nie verkehrt.
Man kann jetzt ja über, man kann ja glaube ich mittlerweile über USB C, ich glaube ab
wann geht das, ab Thunderbolt 4 oder so, kannst du bis zu 200 Watt mittlerweile ziehen.
Ich glaube 20 Volt, was brauchst du mal 20 Volt, 10, 20 Volt, 10 Ampere, rate ich jetzt
einfach mal.
Du kannst ja mittlerweile richtig gut laden, ne ne es geht jetzt USB, geht jetzt bis zu
200 Watt, es ist neu, es ist jetzt neu, ich habe letztens irgendwo gelesen, kann auch
sein, dass ich Mist erzähle, will den mir aber ein, ich habe letztens gelesen, es ist
jetzt neu.
Diese Kombination aus Werten ergibt keinen Sinn, 5 Volt, 2 Ampere, 200 Watt, was, ich
habe das letztens, es kann aber sein, dass ich mich vertan habe, aber ich bilde mir
ein, ich habe letztens gelesen, irgendjemand hat jetzt rausgebracht, dass man vielleicht
auch mit einer Erweite, dass man jetzt bis zu 200 Watt über USB, oder waren es 90, vielleicht
erzähle ich einen Mist, ich habe mich verguckt, es waren auch wirklich nur 90, keine Ahnung.
Na gut, neue Übertragungstechnik, blub blub blub, bla bla bla bla, USB-C Stecker, ja gut,
das sollten sie auch beibehalten, einen neuen Stecker ist wirklich das letzte was USB jetzt
noch braucht.
USB-C Display Link Docking Station sind unter Linux MonkaS, ja das wundert mich nicht,
das erfordert wahrscheinlich wieder Treiberunterschützung an 5 verschiedenen Stellen, die miteinander
können müssen und das ist unter Linux immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Jetzt ernsthaft, weil jeder auch dabei nebenbei zu Patches programmieren kann, ja, natürlich
klar, du darfst dich nur beschweren, wenn irgendwas nicht geht auf deinem Rechner, wenn du selbst
einen Kernel-Mode Treiber programmieren kannst dafür und den dann Open Source einreichst,
das ist klar.
USB-C Buchsen können aber schnell, ja leider, ich muss ja aber ehrlich sagen, es ist immer
noch lieber als Mikro-USB, Mikro-USB ist richtig Panes-Champ gewesen.
Auch ausgeleiert, du konntest nur in eine Richtung reinstecken, ja mal gucken was Intel
damit so treibt, ne, moin Knallibär.
So, ja wir haben noch eine Viertelstunde Zeit, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich als
nächstes Video machen soll, chat, könnt ihr mir mal sagen, also oder mal eure Meinung
zu sagen, also es steht ja immer noch Mac vs Linux vs Windows an, dann habe ich ein Video
geplant über neue Cheats, die man nicht detekten kann, dann habe ich ein Video geplant über
unseren ehemaligen Azubi, der illegales Streaming gehostet hat bei uns im Rechenzentrum, das
wird Panes-Champ, das muss ich wirklich gucken, dass das 100% anonymisiert ist, dass da keiner
irgendwie, da dem noch ein Strick draus dreht oder umgedreht uns, also ich habe da nicht
mitgemacht, muss gleich dazu sagen, ich wusste davon nichts, ich habe das erste erfahren
als der schon weg war, und das vierte Thema habe ich jetzt vergessen, das vierte Thema
habe ich, das war auch nicht schlecht, der Telekom-Ausfall, ja genau, der Telekom-Ausfall,
da wollte ich auch noch ein Video machen, Blizzard-Thema machen, nee, also Blizzard-Thema hat sich
Gott und die Welt schon darüber ausgelassen, ich habe mich auch im Stream schon ein bisschen
dazu ausgelassen, jetzt da drei Wochen nachdem die eigentliche Sache angelaufen ist, ein
Video darüber zu machen, glaube ich, ist verschenkt, außerdem wüsste ich auch nicht, was ich
der ganzen Sache noch neues, irgendwie abgewinnt habe, nee, nee, Abstimmung brauchen wir nicht
auf Twitch machen, wir machen Abstimmung, ich mache Abstimmung in den nächsten Tagen
wieder auf YouTube, kommt noch mal, da kommen noch ein paar, da kommen noch ein paar, ich
meine, guckt mal, ich habe jetzt zwei, ich habe jetzt zwei Videos zu dem Thema gemacht,
ich meine, das sind vielleicht nicht die beliebtesten Videos, weil es halt eben nur ein Teil der
Leute anspricht, aber da kann, ich werde bestimmt noch vier, fünf davon machen. Stimmt, Renax,
du hast Recht, du hast Recht, ich mache das Video mit den Cheats, ja, da hast du Recht.
Übrigens, ähm, meine Frage an dich, wärst du gerne Mod? Kommt jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
überraschend, gebe ich zu, wie ich darauf komme, ist folgendes, du wurdest mir empfohlen,
im Mod Discord Channel, als jemand, der immer Big Brain Comments schreibt und der wohl ein
sehr zuverlässiger Mod wäre. Was kriegt man als Mod? Der Chat mag dich, vielleicht, erst
die nächste dagegen, dann BÄM, Slash Mod, wenn das jetzt funktioniert, BÄM, hat das
funktioniert? Schreibt mal was, ne, oder? Ah, hat funktioniert, Scheiß, Mod Check, ansonsten
hat man davon, dass man Leute timeouten kann, die nerven, aber, aber bitte nur mit Bedacht,
du bist, ne, ich bin ja normalerweise nicht so der Fan von timeouten und wir müssten
glücklicherweise bei mir auch immer sehr wenige Leute timeouten, weil die meisten Leute schon
durch die ganzen Subs mittlerweile so high IQ haben, dass da eigentlich kaum noch Schwachsinn
bei rauskommt, aber manchmal, meistens bei Leuten, die nicht so oft da sind, manchmal
kommt es vor, dass viel Schwachsinn geschrieben wird und da müssen die Mods trotzdem was
spannen, oder zumindest timeouten, oder letztens irgendeiner hat im Discord versucht irgendwelche
Scam Seiten zu spammen und auch direkt Mods direkt auf Zack, BÄM, gebannt. VIP überlege
ich mir, für VIP muss man irgendwas machen, du hast einen VIP Status, weil du Emotes gemacht
hast. Ja, gut, ähm, gibt's denn, ja, also Themen hab ich nicht mehr Leute für heute,
ich hatte ja eh keine, keine großartigen Themen, ich hab jetzt ein bisschen gerantet über
komische Leute in den Kommentaren, über YouTube Lite, äh, über indische VMS, über Sugar
Daddy Apps, Thunderbolt 5, also ich hab noch 10 Minuten Zeit, haben wir noch irgendwas,
haben wir noch irgendwas spannendes, ist heute noch irgendwas spannendes passiert, Hacker
News, Hacker News Leute, Hacker News, was gibt's da, Hacker News, gibt's da irgendwas
spannendes, BÄM, boah, nein, nix spannendes, easy, langweilig, gibt nix, Upload, oh nee,
nee, nee, da will ich nix zu sagen jetzt, das ist ein, ein massives Pains Champ Thema,
so sieht's aus, Annie Primors, hab ich, hab ich Leute vergessen, oh ja, der Kommentator
hat, äh, SubScribe, hab ich gar nicht gesehen, Dankeschön für den Sub, 20 Monate, Mercif
hier, und Heidelberg Trudel vor einer Stunde, Dankeschön Leute, hab ich gar nicht gesehen,
wie sieht's mit dem Speed Champ aus, ich hab den Noel angeschrieben und wir haben uns noch
nicht auf einen neuen Termin geeinigt, könntest du mal mit den Raspberry Pi's, oh nee, das,
es hat mir schon im Packet Tracer gereicht, es hat, es hat mir schon im Packet Tracer
gereicht, ich muss das nicht nochmal machen mit, mit Raspberry Pi's, der Typ vom Discord,
der gespammt hat, ist ein Freund von mir, dessen Discord Account gehackt wurde, da hab
ich so meine Zweifel, der Kell, der im Discord letztens gespammt hat, der hat in der Vergangenheit
schon sinnlose Sachen geschrieben, es gibt Leute, die haben einen Hang dazu dummes Zeug
zu machen und dann müssen sie dann mit auch leben, wenn sie dummes Zeug machen, wenn
es jetzt jemand wäre, der immer nur Big Brain Content von sich gegeben hätte und auf einmal
anfängt zu spammen mit Scam Seiten, dann hätte ich das geglaubt, ja, das Stream war
nice, ne, bei dir ist es ja wenigstens lustig zum größten Teil, gleich ist Bettke, gleich
ist Bettke, also noch nicht, aber dauert nicht mal lang. So, machen wir den ganzen Kreml
mal hier dicht, so Chat, letzte Chance, sieben Minuten, das weiß ich nicht, welche Seite
es war, ich hab das nur mitbekommen, als es schon vorbei war, mit dem Longboard unterwegs,
Longboard, das ist ja, das ist ja so richtig, so richtig 2012, aber nice, muss ich mir erst
mal Gedanken drüber, Solaris VM Installation Speedrun, wie lang braucht man für sowas,
sieben Minuten Semper Video einschalten, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz, was, was erzählt
er uns denn, was erzählt er uns denn, Windows 11 Taskbar verschieben, hallo, in diesem Video
nur ganz kurz die Windows 11 Taskbar, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob mein Intro wenigstens
wieder stimmt, Moment, das müssen wir mal überprüfen, hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz
kurz gezeigt, wie sie ganz einfach die, fast, es war nah dran, aber ich war schon näher
dran, naja gut, wie man die Taskbar, natürlich über Registry Hacks, was sonst Windows, natürlich
über Registry Kacke, kein, nein, mein Microsoft, man macht da keine Optionen, man macht da
kein verschieben, nein, man muss es über Registry Hacks machen, wie bei irgendwelchen
Updates dann aufhören zu funktionieren, Windows ist der Pains Champ in the S, ich sag's euch,
richtig gute Windows, was, Stuckrechts3, das ist ja der most, most random Name aller Zeiten
dafür, Stuckrechts3, 3, was, warum, warum, wobei das in der Welt heißt, dass der Ordner
dafür Stuckrechts, ich krieg mich da mal ein, Alter, das ist so fett, warum heißt es Stuckrechts3,
nicht 2, Leute, nicht 1, nicht 0, 3, Windows, Microsoft, please, es ist noch nicht mal,
es ist noch nicht mal einfach im zusätzlichen Wert, ich muss in irgendeinem ewig lang Binary
X werden, please, Microsoft, ist das wirklich euer Ernst, ja, Neustart, das ist Windows,
Neustarten, Neustarten, Moment, man hat ein Neustarten-Button jetzt im Task Manager drin,
das ist neu, das ist neu, ach ne, nicht recht, der Neustarten, den Dienst Neustarten, ok,
das ist, das ist nicht neu, das ist nicht neu, ja, ich weiß, ich dachte, das ist Neustarten-Knopf
für das Ganze, ne, denn für Dienst Neustarten, die gibt's schon eine Weile, ja, Chat, Chat,
Chat, Chat, ich hab's verstanden, das gibt es schon seit Windows 10, sicher, sicher,
seid ihr euch sicher, gibt's das schon seit Windows 10, ja, ich glaube, ich glaube nicht,
ich glaube euch nicht, guckt euch das, Alter, das ist so unglaublich kompliziert,
Microsoft, meine Güte, muss das echt sein, seid ihr euch sicher, dass das nicht schon
in Windows 8 drinne war, man kann die Taskleiste auch mit Track and Drop umstellen, rechts
klickt drauf, ne, das geht aber nicht mal in Windows 11, das ist weg in Windows 11,
das ginge mal früher, jetzt geht das nicht mehr in Windows 11, ja, stimmt, wie sieht
die Taskleiste seitlich aus, nochmal schreibt mal 02 rein, wie sieht das neben aus, weil
man realistisch betrachtet, ganz im Ernst, theoretisch wäre die Taskleiste auf der linken,
also eine sinnvoll benutzbare Taskleiste wäre auf der linken Seite am besten, weil man hat
natürlich viel mehr horizontalen Space als vertikalen Space mit 16 zu 9, ja, ja, ich
finde, wenn ich die Option jedenfalls finde, faltende Taskleiste, ist das, das, zentriert
genau links, dann wandert das ganze hin, also das davon völlig unbenommen, ja, ok, muss
sein, Mitte ist rausam, triffste Knopf ja gar nicht, wenn du das mit Maus und Tastatur
machen willst, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm,
hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm,
hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, nhmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hmhm, hau hau hau hau, ach, ok, und
der kann auch über die Beschreibung die verlinkte Datei herunterladen, es ist ein ZIP-Paket, ich
will sehen, ich will sehen wie es links aussieht, ich will wissen wie es links aussieht, wie
deswegen ich klicke da nochmal rein
ich habe hier mein zahlrad 3
wie gesagt 01 wäre oben
weil wäre wahrscheinlich links
also klickt
explorer wieder angewählt
neustart ok rechts
aber die icons
die kommen halt nicht
der arbeitet hier ne ganze zeit
dran startet
sich dann auch mitunter noch mehrmals
das magste nicht
das kann sie nicht
das kann sie nicht links
das Windows XP
man könnte denken es ist von
wie kaputt es ist gerade hier
aber ne es ist 11
und unter XP ging das ja
mal gucken vielleicht geht das ja wenn es rauskommt
ich glaube nicht
vielleicht müsste man dafür
vielleicht bräuchte man
wir gehen ja nur gerade anzahlen
vielleicht müssten wir einen Stuck rechts
2 anlegen
damit es links und rechts richtig funktioniert
nach 2 Stunden WLAN Passwort
Brutforcen kannst du mir jetzt zuschauen
hast du dein WLAN Passwort vergessen?
so
wird das ganze hinzugefügt
ok
dann ist er wieder abgestürzt
also ich muss sagen das war für mich
der Witz des Tages
Stuck rechts 3
ich habe überhaupt keine
Probleme damit
dass es
die Registry Einträge gibt
solange wenigstens die sinnvollen
Optionen vorhanden sind
kann auch nicht sein dass man für so einen Scheiß
wirklich Registry Hacks machen muss
ich muss kommen dahin
Microsoft please
Registry Hacks für Taskleister
am oberen Bildschirmrand oder am linken Bildschirmrand
wie sieht das eigentlich in Windows 10
aktuell aus wenn man das an die linke Seite macht
ich meine immerhin funktioniert es
naja Leute
kurzer Stream gewesen
schön dass so viele dabei gewesen sind Poggers
wir sehen uns
im nächsten Stream machs gut
bis denn
see you